hi i'm maria i'm a tasty producer today
as
always i've been challenged to take a
common food
and make it fancy let's see what we are
making fancy today
drum rolls
baby food i might have tried this before
i just don't remember this is a carrot
baby food my baby boy
is four months old he's going to
start baby food soon i think it's a
great opportunity for me to
taste this let's see how it is
it's very runny smells sweet
oh it's actually not bad
it tastes like sweet cooked carrot
what do you think is about sweetness
from carrots
this is maybe the best thing i had in
this
show i think i can make something very
cool with this
so as always i'm excited to
make it fancy all right
here's what i got raisins heavy cream
walnuts orange butter
cream cheese canola oil eggs
and carrots from the pantry
i got flour powdered sugar
brown sugar sugar ground ginger
cinnamon nutmeg baking soda
baking powder vanilla extract salt
and orange liquor
let's get started be careful
make it fancy first step
we are using whole jar of
baby hood put in a
saucepan it's a lot i
love this jar i think i think i'm gonna
clean it and use it for something
else like make jumps or i don't know put
beans i don't know if you have some
ideas let me know
two tablespoons of sugar medium heat
and just cook until sugar dissolve
when you believe that they first started
mass marketing and mass producing baby
food
1940 1920s
oh wow i think sugar has dissolved
now i'm going to pour over into
this silpat the silicone baking ma
and i like this product because
you can use over and over it's
eco-friendly
kind of spreading very thinly
last touch i'm going to bake this in an
oven
200 fahrenheit for two to three hours
so next step use
i'm doing a horrible job opening a bag
i'm going to use one cup and half
walnuts
spread them out you toss this in the
oven at 350 fahrenheit
about five to seven minutes until
fragrant
so we have toasty walnuts it's cool to
touch
and i'm going to chop everything
i sometimes feel like whole walnuts kind
of look like a brain
is it just me cut like rough chop
is that your lady this is not my lady my
lady is at home
still maternity leave recovering
i am making something for
adult because baby cannot eat
what i'm making yet divine
half cup and rest of it
it's in this bowl
and i am going to add
half cup of blessings i don't have any
strong feeding toward lessons
it's like okay i don't hate you and i
don't love you
so half cup of raisins into half cup of
walnut bowl and i'm gonna gently toss
out one tablespoon of flour
i'm gonna mix it well looks good
right we are moving on to next step so
i'm going to measure
out dry ingredients first i
don't need two and a half cup of flour
and one teaspoon of baking soda
two teaspoons of baking powder
half teaspoon of salt quarter teaspoon
of nutmeg one and half teaspoon
of cinnamon and one teaspoon of ginger
and lightly mix smell like autumn
okay so we are going to mix wet
ingredients
first one and a half cup of brown sugar
adding half cup sugar
and one cup of canola oil
four eggs we have more baby food
the same flavor it's a carrot baby food
i'm using
3 4 cup when you are baking sometimes
you use apple sauce but this
baby food works perfect
one teaspoon of vanilla now i'm gonna
just mix
everything
so now i'm going to fold in the dry
ingredients when you are mixing
dry and wet ingredients
change it to spatula so it doesn't get
very tough texture it makes your scrape
inside of the bowl
i developed this symptom
i think it happens to mom a lot called
mom wrist because you are picking up a
baby
over and over you kind of hurts your
wrist and
it's very painful mixing motion
it's a little bit challenging for me i
think i might have to give up
whipping cream with uh
hits by hand it's mixed well it's the
texture of baby food i'm going to peel
carrots i'm grating two carrots
i'm using the biggest hole
of the cheese grater okay so the first
carrot
is almost done now for the second carrot
it's two cups of carrot and
orange zest from one whole orange
raisin and walnut mixture from earlier
folding in and i'm going to
divide butter into three pans if you
want to make sure it's even
you can use scale so each pan
has the same amount of butter spread
this evenly
we are going to bake all three of these
at 350 fahrenheit
about 25 to 30 minutes we baked
this about three hours so the
consistency you're looking for is
look like a fruit leather it's like a
pie ball this is really cool
it's like very thin really have you ever
had a fruit roll
no but i know what it is so this is
why i know the texture maybe you'll have
some
that's the hint and i'm going to
trim the edge cut like half
inch we have reusable straw
kind of thick straw and kind of
make a spiral okay wrap
the smoother side
onto the straw and gently
wrap it if you don't have a straw you
can use any kind of like hanzo like
spatula
or like little so this one is done
after you made a pretty spiral you're
going to
wrap like tight
so you can keep the shape i'm going to
wrap
two more straws with this cara leather
and move on to the next step all right
so i have
one cup of sugar and a quarter cup of
water
make sure water is kind of moist in
all the sugar once you start heating up
you don't want to touch it
if you touch it while you're cooking
this get crystallized and you don't want
that
so i'm going to cook this over medium
high heat about five to seven minutes
until sugar is caramelized and
the color is a little bit like amber
right so color
is nice i'm gonna take off from the heat
and adding two sides of cream
[Music]
whisk and it's get very hot so be
careful
and adding butter one stick
so i'm cutting butter small chunks
because if you drop one stick butter in
the caramel i
don't want to splash all over it's very
dangerous
and just make it melty
and it smells nice and it's tempting but
it's very hot so don't
put your finger in this
and once butter is completely melt
you're going to add two tablespoons of
orange licor
as you know i like using alcohol
yes and you are going to add
two ounces of carrot baby food
to finish pinch of salt right this is
looking good
put in a heat-proof container and put in
a refrigerator until i use
so the texture is a little bit hardened
and
thicker so i have 16 ounce cream cheese
and one stick butter
and i'm going to cream together
butter is a little hard i'm
adding powdered sugar two cups at a time
eight cups in total
ah yeah this is why we are adding two
cups at the time
getting messy it's getting like a
snowball like snowman
last portion
two teaspoons of vanilla
all right looking good
and if it's getting a little bit too
thick you can
add heavy cream to thinning it out
so we are ready to move on so we have
cakes over here and we have frosting
here first i'm going to do crumb coat
and i'm going to take small amount of
frosting
like a glue i'm also glue
the bottom
is this an ice cream scoop
is a good tool to frost cake
because you can make sure same amount of
frosting
is going on top of the cake spread the
frosting evenly
this is our second layer of cake and
second layer of
frosting okay looks good
finally we have third layer of cake
and a sad layer of frosting and whenever
you are going
into frost make sure to clean
so the crumb is not coming into the
fresh batch of
frosting okay so i
coat everything
so we are going to put this in the
freezer for 15 minutes to
make the frosting harden if you don't
have enough space in the freezer
you can put this in the refrigerator for
about 30 minutes
so this cake has been in the freezer for
15 minutes the frosting
is hardened and i'm going to finish this
up
two big scoop i'm adding
new thick layer of frosting and
once the top part is smooth you're going
to walk on
the side when you're decorating cake
office spatula is
important it makes your life easier a
rotating
kickstand is very helpful and you are
just
offset steady and move your kickstand
and it kind of scrapes excess
frosting and make it smooth i feel
like a person who fix wall
because you want to make it smooth
doesn't need to be
too perfect because we are going to coat
with caramel
and walnuts this is a walnut i chopped
earlier
and just like grab handful
and kind of put on the side
cover like two sides of the cake
on the bottom so we are going to put
this in a freezer for 15 minutes to
make frosting harden while cake is in
the freezer
i have my carrot leather
spiral so gently remove from the
straw kind of hold the shape
that's in the sugar these are looking
good
time to get the cake so i have caramel
i made earlier it's still kind of runny
and i'm going to pour this on top and
kind of let the caramel to drip by
itself
so more i pour on top it's
kind of dripping like a drip cake drip
drip
caramel dripped nice and i'm going to
put it in the freezer just like
hot in the caramel about five minutes
and do the final decorating
cake is out from the freezer i'm going
to decorate
i got frosting in a piping bag i feel
like i'm doing a little bit too big so
i'm gonna just do five
we have baby food in
a cake we have a baby food in a caramel
we have baby food in the spiral
so frosting is looking good and i'm
going to put
the carrot spiral
on top and we are done
[Music]
baby food carrot cake super fancy
thank you so much for watching i hope
you make a home if you make it tag me on
instagram and don't forget to dance make
it fancy
[Music]
wow